[Music]
here's quite a story for you a
77-year-old Florida man was arrested by
the feds accused of having thousands of
dollars worth of illegal pills used to
treat erectile
dysfunction
mhm where's the crime the justice
department says Reginald Kinser had more
than yeah that's a guy who has a lot of
boner pills that guy who has a bunch of
boner pills that's the face of a man who
has an unlimited Supply boner pills
that's a lot of boner pills this guy has
oh man you're right he looks so happy
and of course it's because of all the
boners and of course he's in the village
justice department says Reginald Kinser
had more than
$1,800 worth of the pills that were
offbrand stashed in his house so who
gives a [__] I'm sorry so basically what
was happening was they were off he was
buying probably generic Viagra from one
of those Shady online pharmacies some
Indian Pharmacy or some [__] and then he
figured I'm I'll just buy a bunch I'll
just buy a bunch of them and they only
come in like [__] huge like number
sizes well honestly though he was
probably selling a little bit of them
Villages but I mean you know but I'm
sure he wasn't like running a goddamn
you know open for is this what the feds
are doing like just stopping an old man
from having fake SE not having F sorry
offbrand seis yeah because I mean we
we've I don't know if you notice Roy but
maybe Royce is just a little ungrateful
but we've had it pretty good in America
last couple years have been pretty
smooth all right we really got crack
down on the small stuff you yeah cuz you
know everything else is perfect he
allegedly got without a prescription
from a licensed doctor with plans to
redistribute the drug what he got him
without a prescription from a licensed
St drugs in and outside of the state but
the kicker here according to the feds he
was Distributing them to elderly people
living at The Village's retirement
community I knew
it yeah cuz that's literally like you're
basically like what freeway Rick Ross
was to cocaine in the 80s like if you if
you have a bunch of unless boner pills
and you live in The Villages I'm sorry
but do we all love this guy now cuz he
was basically a boner a Robin Hood bone
a b boner Robin Hood guy he was going
around town and you didn't notice she
say selling them Distributing them so
just probably just handing them out to
to like people who wanted them and
residents say they're disappointed that
he got arrested push it to the
limit he's on the phone with so s did
you hear what counting his money did you
hear what the resident said and
residents say they're disappointed that
he got arrested because he was the boner
pill guy for the villages yeah here's
the thing right like this is great I
love this all my life right like when
the Coke guy or the local weed guy that
everybody like got busted yeah everyone
was bummed great have you ever had a
good weed guy that was a solid dude for
years yeah and then he gets arrested
everyone in and everyone's talking about
it like when I worked at strip clubs you
come in youd be like yo did you heard
Derek got arrested I know dude I can't
find anything right now Jim Edwards
keeps keep playing it gets better
consider him the neighborhood pharmacist
absolutely that's what we do help a girl
out well I'm just sorry he got busted
before I had a chance to buy from him
look dude everybody loved him he was a
folk hero in The
Villages oh my goodness kiner I
shouldn't be laughing but he he is
facing some serious charges that could
lead to a yearlong in federal they're
not going to stick this man in a year in
federal prison there's no [__] way
that's going to happen if they do that's
a joke prison but clearly they were
getting it on at the retirement center
and they're disappointed in this not
hiding that fact either it's just SE
Alis who or fagar with one of the two
who cares right this is another one of
those who gives a [__] and that has to
be the happiest not to mention it's it's
not even like it's one of those drugs
that
frankly you could get without like
Skyping with a you can go online and
just fill out a thing and they'll send
it to you in the mail it's not like it's
not like he was [__] pressing fental
oxycon bills or
something